okay well first of all thank you for
doing this with us it's so good to see
you
yeah zu ether I know it's so good to see
you the last time I saw you was at the
Create cultivate event when people could
actually congregate I know and here we
are like in our homes in our homes I
know it how are you doing how's the
family doing with all of this you know I
have to say this is almost almost two
weeks so almost day 14 for me and it's
starting to get to me the first week I
was like yeah you know this is great you
know I'm at home like this is awesome
I'm chilling but then you know I mean to
be honest with you yesterday was was a
little even today it's a little
overwhelming for me I was meditating
because it's one way on how we've been
staying sane in the house and I just
started to cry I literally just started
bawling and that had never happened to
me before with like meditation and I
think it's because I I was focusing on
everyone else and not necessarily myself
I was focusing on how do I keep the kids
busy how I'm making dinner how do I keep
my husband busy
Kairo just kind of juggling everything
increase pooling online that I wasn't
able to really tap into my own feelings
and what I was going through or feeling
about this whole situation so you know
we're doing okay when you have those
moments those tearful moments those
emotional moments how do you kind of
pull yourself out of that and what's
like the biggest trigger do you think I
think well first of all it's me answer
your question on how do I pull myself
out of that moment I have to give a lot
of credit to my husband because we were
meditating together and it's something
that we've been doing together and we
looked at each other and he was like you
know it's gonna be okay we got this you
got this this will all be over you know
we just don't know when but you know
know that everything will be okay that's
one of them
main things that helps me get out of
this is just a support for my husband
the other question you would ask me what
was the other question you would ask me
I mean just you realized you weren't
really having enough me oh yeah it was
in the trigger so I think the trigger
for me is looking at statistics and
watching and see watching and seeing how
quickly this virus is affecting so many
people I mean just yesterday I think we
were close to 55,000 people in the
United States alone and then also seeing
how in China it's actually affecting us
a little differently meaning that not
only the elderly are being affected but
also you know children I think the first
casualty of a young person was a few
days ago and I think they were like yeah
and just reading that just made me go oh
my gosh like what is going on so I would
definitely have to say just kind of
focusing and honing in on statistics
gonna get me there and sometimes I just
kind of have to just like you know also
it's good to be informed but I think
it's also important to focus on
positivity with with with all of what's
unfortunately going on and the positive
thing is just you know you know
hopefully we will have this under
control we're doing you know everything
that we possibly can do and just being
here with my family has been very very
amazing that's the thing about this the
one silver lining I think is that people
are getting to spend more time with
their loved ones right which is really
really special
how are you talking to your kids about
what's going on and how are they doing
I'm very particular about words and
things that I'm saying to them I have
mentioned of course the coronavirus and
what it is but I haven't talked to them
about the consequences of it I think
just much to put on you know Crete I
don't want him to be you know incredibly
anxious or scared so but I am telling
him you know what the corona virus is
and it's making people sick and we have
to stay inside because it's very
contagious make sure we wash our hands
but everything's gonna be okay mommy and
daddy you know we're we're here for you
so that's I'm kind of keeping it very
brief yeah but I'm trying to keep
everything light and and and positive
for him I don't think he'll be able to
handle what's really going on sure I
mean he's he's young is he asking
questions like why aren't I in school
right now that kind of thing yes so he
is so he has asked the question you know
mommy why can't I go to school and I
told him because of the corona outbreak
and I said you know it's very contagious
and don't want anybody else you know
getting sick and you don't want anybody
else also you know spreading the virus
so we have to stay home I did tell him
that it was going to be for a very long
time but I have to say my son has been a
G and what I mean by that is I mean gang
stuff that is he's really adapted very
well with online schooling it's for
three and a half hours and he loves the
way it's set up you actually get to see
all of the kids online and who sees his
teacher and it just makes him laugh kind
of takes his mind away from what's going
on so he's been doing very well
adjusting with that he's also been able
to play a a lot of video games and you
know we've been doing a lot of tape
talking like family so I know some I've
read some are they don't need to be
playing video games I'm like guys come
on like let your kid be a kid yeah I
mean come on and this is you know a time
where they could just you know have some
fun to get their mind off of what's
really going on
I'm so
I don't mind him being on his his um his
iPad and playing video games and so he's
really loving that
oh he's adjusting very well we're
cooking together we made some blueberry
muffins the other day made some chicken
piccata with some pasta
garlic bread like so just keeping him
busy cooking and playing games yeah
that's all you can do right yeah how's
your sister doing I mean I know that
we're all sort of grunting right now are
you able to see your family through all
this that to be honest with you has been
the hardest part of course I get to see
my family
my husband and my children but not being
able to see I'm about to cry sorry no
it's okay
I wish I could like reach out oh you're
fine there's somebody inside a question
but not to be able to see my dad my
brothers and my sister has been pretty
hard because we're all very close you
know but um we've handled it very well
with um sorry
with FaceTime each other so we've been
faced giving each other my brother the
other day you show me what he made for
dinner and it's like crazy how we're
getting excited about the simple things
like look what I baked for dinner you
know I'm constantly checking up on his
well-being like how are you doing
emotionally especially with my dad and
my mom you know because they're older
and that's why I think it's just so
important to stay inside you know what I
mean like I always say my insane it's
you know safer at home and staying at
home saves lives so but anyway I'm able
to talk to my mom and my dad on FaceTime
we talk like almost every day my sister
has well been texting each other you
know she's doing well she's you know
with her kids but I believe that's been
the hardest you know just not being able
to you know
your loved ones but we're gonna get
through this
yeah it's it's all gonna be good so
sorry no you're okay I think we're all
kind of feeling that way and I think
about all the people who live alone and
don't even have walls family to be with
and I think I know a freaking thing
about this and it's really humanizing
all of us and it's making us realize
we're all in this together ever be your
regular celebrity in Athleta bar like
we're all going we're going do you guys
together
yep do you have plans for after this
like something you guys are gonna do or
you can't wait to do with that Cree's
birthday's coming up
and even Cairo's birthday's coming up
Kairo who is May 5th and I'm not sure
you know I don't know what's gonna
happen and we were planning on you know
going out to dinner as a family for
kairos birthday because we do a big
birthday party for her last year but for
Cree and we were gonna go to Knott's
Berry Farm he's always wanted to go so
hopefully I mean that's in June so
hopefully once this is all over and
hopefully it'll be okay by June to just
take the whole family you know out you
know to the amusement park and celebrate
my son's ninth birthday so that's what
I'm hoping to do is just to have a huge
celebration with with you know my family
and and and my brother and my sister and
my mom and my dad and all of us
celebrate Crees ninth birthday yeah
here's a little bit I mean your show is
streaming on Netflix and I know everyone
that I've talked to you all they're
doing is watching Netflix how's the
reaction been for you to people watching
family reunions are you know oh yeah let
me tell you the coolest reaction for me
is seeing how this show it has been able
to translate to different countries so
on my Instagram a lot of people have
been posting in their stories the show
with me speaking in German
that'd be a trip I would imagine right
me speaking in French one I think was
even from Brazil it's just been so
rewarding to see that and I'm talking
about it's fair the show is very multi
general type cultural I'm not like oh
yeah multicultural and multinational so
to see younger kids like it to you know
older people liking it
to moms you know like me liking it and
just just seeing its range of people
just enjoying the show has been really
really really rewarding how has this
time sort of affected your other
projects I know you were getting ready
to maybe yeah yeah you know I have to
say there was one project well you know
a lot of projects have been put on hold
but you know right now it's like that's
not not what matters you know it's like
for me what matters is we get this virus
situation you know we have a hold of it
and you know we don't have you know
people dying from this and that's kind
of like what I've been been focusing and
putting my attention on it's just
focusing on that um but I'm not alone
you know a lot of stuff has been put on
hold and a lot of you know crazy stuff
well not crazy stuff but a lot of stuff
has been put to a halt but but none that
matter see though right now what matters
is people you know being healthy and
safe and well I know a lot of people
that I've talked to have said that this
is made them feel more present do you
feel like that's what's been for you
with your your family yeah you know we
even talked about just with the whole
Kobe Bryant situation the last time just
like I think 2020 that's just made me
and I feel like everyone else just very
present
um you know especially being in the
house and just focusing on the things
that matter Michael my husband I said I
feel like wastin a lot of people are
just gonna have a different perspective
and a different view on things you know
a lot of people are gonna be changing
their minds about whether it's their
jobs or you know whatever doesn't make
them happy they're gonna be you know
moving towards things that make them
happy I just think that people are gonna
have a different perspective on things
after all of this and I think that's a
good thing
you know what I mean sometimes we need
to just sit down and you know focus and
be present on what's going on
in front of us not far out you know what
I mean and yeah and I think it's gonna
benefit all of us in in in the long run
so definitely being more present I'm
sure like some couples are variously I
think it was your sister that posted and
she was really embracing the anti beauty
aspect of all of this how are you
handling that I think as women and
especially in the industry we kind of
get caught up you know yes like the gray
hairs and all that yeah I mean all right
I am you know what I'm doing I'm doing
pretty good
I mean look my nails are done and that's
okay my eyebrows when I did my makeup
today for you guys okay I was like oh my
god I was filling in like but you know I
think you just I had seen a video of I
don't know who it was but there were
some officials in Italy or something
like that and they were talking about
how they were appalled at people who
were ordered to stay home going to the
hair salon and it's like guys come on
that's not important it's about putting
things
to perspective right now what is
important your health other people's
health your well-being your mental
health
like let's focus on that like let's not
focus on if I have hair you know growing
and my eyebrows are no longer nicely
coughed and shaped like come on a little
bit freeing though and a little bit nice
to kind of like let things
yeah just it is it is I have shaved
though I washed in four days right right
whatever you if there's women if they're
women out there that you know want to
grow their their hair out then do it do
you you but it is it's very free it's
very liberating and these are the things
that I think that we can learn once all
of this is over it's like you know to
hold on to those things that you learned
while you were in quarantine and apply
it because there's a lot of lessons that
are being taught whether you want to
believe it or not yeah I do want to play
a rapid-fire game with you but my gosh
you always like to play just kind of fun
okay you're go to quarantine snack or go
to quarantine snack or food of choice
would definitely have to be chips
whether that's BBQ chips salt and
vinegar chips just the regular salty
chips by kettle
very good okay what shows are you
binging right now and what is on your
list of been Jeanette okay so if you ask
me this question fryer quarantine I mean
of course I would be telling you shows
it's like you know shows for the fur for
adults but now everybody's in the house
so it's like you act and watch family
shows go go Cory Carson which is the kid
I've been been binge watching everything
on Disney Plus so from tangled
I cannot tell you how many times I
watched tingled mallanna Oh huh I want
you to be a Disney at Disney movie like
it Disney Princess I've also been want
binge watched well it's a movie coupe
point which was of my brothers movie on
Disney Channel I haven't seen that movie
projects that will be in years so
basically it's been on Disney bless you
know what my husband's been doing though
I think this is hilarious because
there's no NBA there's no games on so my
husband is going a little stir-crazy cuz
that's all he watches like he watches
basketball games all the time so now
he's watching old basketball games on
YouTube yeah yeah so he'll just sit
there and watch basketball games from
like years ago I'm like oh my god yeah
any hobbies that you're taking up or
anything that you used to love to do
that night you have the time to do again
oh that's actually a really really good
question um you know what I have to say
like reading you know I mean I don't
know when the last time I was able to
pick up a book and like be able to
actually read the book I mean I do a lot
of audios because I'm in the car I'm on
the plane I'm always on the go but um my
husband actually just he said it the
other day who's like Tia let's read a
book together when does that happen
when does that happen and I was like
okay we just gotta find a book to read
them together but um no yeah so that's
definitely been something on my list
that we're gonna do that we're gonna do
together that we never thought about
doing before yeah husband in any way
reading I think it's great
yeah okay know what the other thing is I
think I'm gonna be making pasta I've
never made pasta from scratch
homemade pasta so I'm gonna try to do I
may do this live on my Instagram I may
not but I'm gonna have a really really
good friend of mine who knows how to
make pasta from scratch and we're gonna
like FaceTime each other and we're gonna
learn how to make pasta together so from
from scratch so I'm she knows how to
make it I wanna know how to make them
scratch from her so I can't wait to do
that right yeah I know okay the first
beauty appointment that you're gonna
make after this is all done
definitely manicure and pedicure get my
nose nodes done you know it's just
something that I was was doing on you
know every two weeks I would do it and
then also get a massage oh my gosh get a
massage go to the chiropractor just
those things have like feel-good things
you know what I mean like you need a
good massage you take yeah I was telling
my husband met you I was like look see
these are the lessons it's like like we
we take so much for granted that you
don't even realize that you do like like
you know I would love to see my
chiropractor right now you know you know
I'm gonna get a nice massage carrying
Cairo but you know do this stuff like
that you have maybe like a mental health
tape whether it's like doing at home
workouts like anything that's sort of
keeping you yeah definitely um what has
been helping me is doing workouts at
home and I just did a live workout the
other day on my Instagram it was so much
fun
like 60,000 people I was like oh my gosh
it's incredible like to to join in on a
workout like when does that happen
so that was really cool um I run on my
treadmill
I'm a huge fan of peloton oh my god
like peloton thank God I got my peloton
before all of this I think they're all
is backordered like everything so but
yeah
exercising has been meditating calm
there's a calm app that I use that it's
just incredible I would say those things
I think it's important to keep moving
you know and then to just get outside
every now and then I'm even looking at
the clouds right now and I'm telling you
I have never seen the clouds in LA and
the sky looks so clear and the clouds
being so nice and puffy like it's crazy
crazy but just get outside
put your feet it's called grounding like
put your feet on the grass just so you
can kind of like become one with nature
a little bit I actually told my dad to
do that and he was like Tia thank you so
much for telling me to do that and I
told my dad to meditate as well and that
has really helped him sort of a fun one
what's your like live-in outfit right
now choice are you sweat are you putting
jeans on no okay so I have my moment so
you know like I said we're two weeks in
right now we have a long way to go I
mean we're in I think they said we maybe
April something
some days I'm in sweats don't get me
wrong like some days I'm walking around
in sweats feeling very comfortable but
other days I just want to dress up like
the other day I put on my Instagram my
daughter and I we were wearing the same
dresses like these lemonade dresses and
I just wanted to just you know kind of
get ready and just kind of get dressed
and dressed up so I have been walking
around and kind of like flowy springy
dresses just to you know get my mind off
of you're gonna mean you're inside you
know when you can't really go outside
way to like make ourselves feel a little
bit better right yes it is
it's almost like when they say when you
clean out your your room or your closet
it makes you feel better like your mood
it's the same way I feel like how it
makes me feel oh and I just kind of get
dressed for a minute but I'm not like
that all the time
you know nobody got time for that too
much it's too much energy but uh but
some days like I do want to dress
dressed up and you know do my hair and
you know look presentable yeah I get
that
and then before they let you go and by
the way thank you for doing this again
with us it's so nice oh my gosh no
problem um do you have a message of hope
that you want to give to your fans and
people watching who are having a hard
time right now are confused by all the
different reports in the news you know
my message would be just to hang in
there and you're not alone I think when
when you feel like you're not the only
one that's going through this like the
whole world is going through this it
just makes you feel a little bit better
and that's kind of like what I've been
you know meditating on is that also your
so I've been meditating on you're not
alone which has been really really
helping me out um and also to meditate
on the things that you can control and
not necessarily focusing on the things
that you can't control because when you
focus on the things you can't control
then that's when you start to well I
know for me I start to have anxiety and
I just start to get anxious and I just I
just don't feel good but if I focus on
the things that I can do it makes me
just feel a little bit better so that's
what I would want to tell everybody out
there you got this you can do this stay
in side staying inside saves lives and
just you know hope it'll all be over
soon so thank you my favorite okay I'll
have to do this again
yes give your kids a big hug well inside
be safe and thank you you're sending you
lots of love and hugs right now okay all
right
[Music]